[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition spéciale sur tv 78 nous sommes
le mardi 12 mai
après la mort du déconfinement hier
c'était un retour très attendu très
redouté aussi la rentrée des classes
pour les maternelles et primaires peu
d'élèves cependant concernés aujourd'hui
seuls 23% des écoliers sur le territoire
était attendu d'après le directeur
académique des yvelines
les établissements comme ici à
guyancourt ont dû repenser leur espace
réaménagé les emplois du temps pour
favoriser les mesures de distanciation
sociales et des classes limitée de 5 à
10 élèves en maternelle de 10 à 15
élèves en élémentaire et dans les
yvelines 918 d965 écoles vont rouvrir
progressivement une réflexion est encore
en cours pour les autres établissements
qui reste fermé à saint quentin en
yvelines vous le voyez sur cette
animation six communes ont effectué une
réouverture de leur école dès
aujourd'hui quatre autres suivront le
pas jeudi et les deux dernières ce sera
la semaine prochaine un principe commun
celui de la progressivité seul quelques
classes et quelques élèves sont pour
l'heure accueillis contactez votre école
ou votre mairie pour connaître les
conditions précises de l'organisation de
cette rentrée si le déconfinement est
actée depuis hier lundi l'épidémie de
covile 19 n'est pas encore terminée l
etat les équipes de santé et les
collectivités sont toujours sur le
terrain pour identifier accompagner les
malades et leurs proches dans les
yvelines une cellule d'appui à
l'isolément vient de voir le jour à
versailles une visite était organisée ce
matin à sur place mélanie poté qui est
un rouge
effectivement quand vous avez une
température de 5 ans respiratoires
accélérée des informations données par
les patients qu'au vu de positif placé
en isolement
les résultats sont suivis par cindy
infirmières libérales sur versailles
elle fait partie de la cellule d'appui
la cellule d'appui et de coordination
départementale
il n'y a pas de consultation il n'y a
pas de prise en charge médicale directe
n'y a pas de téléconsultation on est en
appui pour trouver une solution sur le
territoire pour le patient donc
sollicité un médecin traitant trouver un
médecin traitant et ensuite surveiller
les paramètres vitaux
cette cellule travail avec les
généralistes les 1400 médecin de famille
benoît sont le premier niveau de la
stratégie sanitaire
un dispositif lancé l'un d'eux
11 mai qui regroupe diverses entités la
préfecture du département l' agence
régionale de santé mais aussi des
associations de secours on sait qu'on
aura en ile-de-france à peu près 1000
contamination par jour il faut qu'on
repère ces gens il faut qu on en repère
la majorité et qu'à partir d'une
personne kobe de plus qui aura été
repéré par son médecin généraliste
on va remonter ces cas le médecin
généraliste va dialoguer avec elle sur
qui a dans la cellule familiale
et puis va aussi commencé à l'interroger
éventuellement sur les contacts qu'il a
eus il va transmettre ces données à
l'assurance maladie et des plateformes
de l'assurance maladie dans chaque
département vont passer les coûts de
fuite en cas de suspicion d'un foyer
comme dans une école un ehpad ou un
foyer de travailleurs
l'agencé régionale de santé prend le
relais forte actuellement d'une
vingtaine de personnes la cellule
yvelinoise est amenée à grandir en
fonction des besoins
mais voilà pour cette cellule dédiée
dans les yvelines le département qui a
enregistré hier soir 4 155 décès est lié
aux coronavirus dans les hôpitaux
cette de plus en 24 heures avec une
tendance qui se confirme depuis
plusieurs jours le nombre
d'hospitalisations et de réanimation est
à la baisse 718 patients étaient
hospitalisés hier sur le territoire 67
toujours en réanimation
et puis 1600 personnes sont désormais
guéri est revenu à domicile après un
séjour en établissement hospitalier
dans l'actualité du jour aussi le
déplacement du ministre de l'agriculture
dans les yvelines didier guillaume s'est
rendu à versailles puis à saint-rémy
l'honorer visite sur place de la ferme
renard pour faire le bilan de huit
semaines de confinement est notamment
sur le retour en vogue des circuits
courts le reportage de mathilde demi
visite masqué afin rémy l'honorer dans
la ferme de la famille renard tout en
respectant les gestes barrière le
ministre de l'agriculture didier
guillaume a rencontré les agriculteurs
de l'exploitation pour tirer avec eux le
bilan du confinement nous au niveau
français nous devons assumer que nous
sommes un pays en avance sur les
productions agricoles que nous avons un
savoir faire hors du commun que ce chat
dwarf ce savoir faire doit être reconnue
et moi je veux assumer que ici des
personnes qui sont là plus
continuer à vendre des produits de
qualité soit directement aux gens qui
viennent soit par diverses façons demain
je crois que le commerce alimentaire
changera favoriser les petits artisans
et des producteurs locaux se rendre
directement dans les fermes et sur les
marchés les yvelinois ont changé leur
façon de consommer pendant le
confinement on append de repenser notre
façon de consommer pendant le continent
parce qu'on n'avait plus le choix
donc on est allé à la ferme directement
pour acheter des produits parce que on
trouvait peut-être trop risqué d'aller
parfois dans des grands centres
commerciaux parce que certains étaient
fermés ou parce que les marchés
alimentaires étaient fermés on a moins
pu commander des choses sur internet
parce que certains services ne
fonctionnait plus donc on s'est adapté
pour la ferme renard le confinement a
peut impacter leur activité les marchés
ayant fermé pour la plupart ils ont vu
leur clientèle augmenter et leur chiffre
d'affaires est restée globalement le
même la désorganisation la surcharge de
travail font que la marge on est réduite
le chiffre d'affaires s'est maintenu
mais les charges ont gonflé donc
fatalement l'année s'annonce comme étant
moins bonne que l'année précédente en
terme de résultat comptable maintenant
on peut pas dire on peut pas dire qu'on
soit gravement impacté on s'en sort très
bien
les douze salariés de l'exploitation
poursuivront leur production et espèrent
que leurs clients continueront à venir
jusqu'à leur ferme pour soutenir les
producteurs yvelinois mais vous l'avez
vu dans ce reportage le confinement
tient impacter le fonctionnement des
exploitations
c'est le cas aussi pour d'autres
secteurs de l'économie comme le bâtiment
plusieurs semaines d'arrêt avant une
reprise amorcée il ya peu le point sur
la situation dans les yvelines
dans cet entretien mené par mélanie
poker bonsoir bernard attal vous êtes
délégué général de la fédération
française du bâtiment dans les yvelines
la ffb a réalisé une enquête auprès de
ses adhérents et des prospects du
bâtiment pour savoir comment les
artisans et entrepreneurs avaient vécu
cette période de confinement
quelles sont les premières conclusions
que vous pourrez faire de pourriez faire
de cette enquête
bonsoir et merci de donner la parole
donc la première
analyse que l'on a de cette enquête
c'est de dire que le colis de 19 a été
pour nous une bombe
quelque chose de surnaturel qui nous est
tombé dessus et il ya eu un phénomène de
sidération au départ et d'ailleurs ça se
ressent très bien dans cette enquête
puisque 90 90 à 95% de la population de
nos adhérents et prospects c'est à dire
que tout le secteur du bâtiment dans les
yvelines s'est arrêté oui parce que
c'est un secteur qui n'est pas parce
possibilité de faire de télétravail
presque 90% n'a pas pu il recourir il
faut dire que nos emplois sont
essentiellement à 70% des emplois de
production des emplois de terrain nous
avons effectivement quelques emplois
dans les bureaux des emplois de
conducteurs de travaux de métreur qui
ont pu se faire par télétravail
d'ailleurs dans l' enquête nous avons
constaté que à peu près 15 % de nos
effectifs ont pu être mis en télétravail
un jeu qui est une bonne chose par
rapport aux 25 % de ses effectifs
attractif nous avons également à peu
près 10% de personnes qui ont été mis en
arrêt maladie du fait de la garde des
enfants de moins de 16 ans et il reste
du personnel pour les entreprises qui se
sont arrêtés a été mis en chômage
partiel et 97 % des entreprises ont
souhaité reprendre leur activité ça fait
quand même repris dès le 20 avril
comment ça s'est passé
alors ça s'est passé pas toujours de
manière simple parce qu'il ya une peur
quasi panique de ducobu de 19 et du
travail sur coville 19
ça s'est passé difficilement notamment
avec les clients essentiellement
particulier dans cette période là parce
que les particuliers à leur domicile et
que ben ils voulaient pas forcément
accueillir des personnes qui venaient de
l'extérieur alors qu'eux mêmes se
confiner et puis ça s'est passé
difficilement parce que nous n'avons pas
encore inventé le système pour
travailler sans faire de bruit ni faire
de poussière et vous comprenez que les
copropriétés notamment qu'ils étaient
occupés par les personnes confinées
n'appréciez pas de
de voir et d'entendre du bruit pendant
la journée en ce qui concerne des
chantiers ce qu'on va appeler les plus
gros chantiers les chantiers structuré
construction de logements neufs et c'est
là les champions ont été purement et
simplement arrêter puisque dont 99% des
cas ce sont nos maîtres d'ouvragé qui
nous ont imposé l'arrêt de chantier et
est ce que dans cette reprise d'activité
du côté des salariés y avait des
inquiétudes lié peut-être un manque de
matériel de protection
est ce que les entreprises ont pu se
fournir correctement alors dans un
premier temps vous parliez du mois
d'avril c'est certain que là il y avait
des difficultés à trouver des masques à
trouver du gel etc etc
nous avons même été en mesure pour
certains nos adhérents dans d'offrir à
la préfecture des yvelines pour les
services médicaux des yvelines et
ensuite on a voulu reprendre justement
fin avril on avait de grandes
difficultés à s'en procurer
maintenant ça commence à être beaucoup
plus simple on a en arrivant en trouver
auprès de nos fournisseurs et je tenais
aussi à souligner le rôle de la du
conseil régional d'île de france qui a
commandé un certain nombre de millions
de masques et qui vient d'en remettre au
medef nous en a remis une dotation que
nous allons distribuer entre aujourd'hui
et demain aux adhérents et aux projets
de la fédération du bâtiment des
yvelines est ce que à ce jour vous mener
des chantiers sont encore dans
l'incertitude des entreprises ne savent
pas comment va être leur avenir alors
aussi bien au niveau des grands
chantiers que des petits chantiers de
particuliers nous avons des incertitudes
puisque nous avons toujours des
personnes qui sont assistées confiné qui
sont chez elles des personnes qui qui
ont le corps vide qui sont à risque
puisque vous savez même de pathologies
qui indique qu'il faut pas être en
contact avec une personne qui est
cardiaque une personne qui assure quoi
une personne qu'il ya d'autres
pathologies
et donc ça nous pose problème parce que
ça nous empêche j'avais sur un certain
nombre de chantiers sur les chantiers
plus structurée des entreprises plus
conséquente
là encore nous avons la problématique de
l'organisation puisque dans ces
chantiers nous avons dû mettre en place
un pépé espèce nouveau et ce pps nouveau
nous a imposé de
de d'avoir des techniques nouvelles de
travail de protection de nos salariés
nous avons dû minimiser les risques de
l'aco activité ce que vous savez sur les
chantiers il n'y a pas forcément qu'un
seul corps d'état il peut y en avoir
plusieurs
les salariés peuvent se croiser peuvent
pas risquer de toucher et donc c'est
assez difficile à organiser
d'ailleurs à ce sujet si vous le
permettez c'est une de nos premières
problématique c'est celle du coup tu
on s'est rendu compte que le coût de nos
chantiers est de l'ordre de 10 à 15%
supérieur à notre masse salariale
vous fixez anormaux l'idée c'est c'est
plus d'une trentaine d'euros par jour et
par gars et on peut re calcul est très
rapidement ces écoutes
en intégrant les trois masques
chirurgicaux qui va falloir utiliser
dans la journée le gel hydroalcoolique
les surcotes qui va falloir mettre plus
les temps d'habillage des habillages que
l'on avait pas précédemment pour ce type
de matériel plus les temps de lavage des
mains plus là non productivité qu'on va
avoir du fait qu'on va être un petit peu
moins nombreux sur les chantiers et du
fait également que harnachés de la sorte
c'est plus difficile de travailler on a
moins de rentabilité
donc là notre problématique c'est
d'arriver à facturer ce surcoût de notre
masse salariale sur les chantiers déjà
conclu donc c'est une négociation avec
nos maîtres d'ouvragé publics et privés
qui est pas toujours simple
et puis dans l'avenir 6 il convient d
toujours présent là falloir intégrer une
ligne covic 19 spécifique sur l'eau de
vie qui corresponde à ce sur le chat
tenais à vous dire que ce surcoût est
quand même très important puisque la
masse salariale d'une entreprise du
bâtiment
si environ 50 à 70% de son chiffre
d'affaires il faut savoir que nos
entreprises font en moyenne 2 0 à 2 et
demi pour cent de résultats par an donc
on vous fait 50 à 70 % de chiffre
d'affaires et que vous remettez ça par
rapport aux résultats
ça veut dire que si nos clients
n'acceptent pas de prendre en charge au
moins
de saussure ou ce que moi je vais
appeler la solidarité dans ces
conditions c'est la mort d'entreprise à
terme parce qu'elles vont vendre leur
prestation beaucoup moins cher que cela
ne leur coûte
merci bernard attal je le rappelle vous
êtes délégué général de la fédération
française du bâtiment dans les yvelines
merci ce devait être le plus beau jour
de leur vie mais avec l'épidémie de kovy
19 de nombreux couples ont dû se
résoudre à un report de leur mariage
selon le fondateur du salon spécialisé
se sont même 50% des unions prévu cette
année qui ont été soit différée soit
annulée elle nous avons posé trois
questions à la divine oise virginie
mention à ce sujet elle est la
cofondatrice de la sauce m l'association
des consultants en mariage et wedding
planner
c'est le calendrier c'est est ce qu'on
va encore on peut retenter en fin
d'année en septembre octobre on a encore
des beaux jours
donc on peut reporter les mariages ou
est ce que ça sera pas possible parce
que il ya encore des restreinte au
niveau par exemple d'une mondes habités
ou autre donc voilà est-ce qu'on repart
en septembre octobre où est-ce qu'on
reporte en 2004
on a fait un petit sondage ou simple de
la sauce m
pour connaître effectivement le nombre
de mariages qui va être reporté sur 2021
on a estimé qu'il y avait environ 30%
des mariages 2020 qui était déjà reporté
en 2021
et pourtant en fait si un manque à
gagner parce que du coup c'est 30% là ce
sont des mariages de mineures atteint
qui n'auront pas lieu en 2021
enfin des coupes de 2021 qui vont pas
pouvoir se marier en 2021
c'est vraiment un manque à gagner pour
pour la profession et pour l'industrie
du mariage en général est effectivement
du coup c'est ça complique un coteau
pendant sept années 2020 on va avoir
très peu de rentrées d'argent
donc c'est comment est ce qu'on va vivre
pendant cette année là puisque si la
plupart des mariages sont reportés en
c'est à dire qu'en 2020 notre saison est
vraiment computer donc comment est ce
qu'on fait est ce qu'on peut vraiment
vivre une année sans rien est-ce que
voilà est-ce que l'état va être à la
hauteur des aides qu'il promet donc là
pour l'instant on peut chacun touché
mais les 1500 euros de fonds de
solidarité mais on espère vraiment et
c'est pour ça qu'on a interpellé
bruno le maire on espère vraiment que
c'était de la va se prolonger au delà du
mois de mai parce qu'en fait nous on est
on va vraiment être les derniers à
pouvoir redémarrer de l'activité donc on
estime même que l'on va avoir des
incidences sur 2021
[Musique]
pour les couples qui n'ont pas de
wedding planner ça peut être
effectivement de se rapprocher d'un
wedding planner pour essayer de
reprendre un peu en main l'organisation
peut être les accompagner dans les
autres dans les repas et puis ça va être
de patienter aussi de prendre son mal en
patience et puis ne restez à l écoute
des annonces du gouvernement
pendant le confinement qui a duré deux
mois on a vu énormément de marques
d'affection envers les soignants ses
applaudissements à la fenêtre et aux
balcons que vous avez sans doute vu tous
les soirs à 20h et des musiciens eux
aussi ont décidé de dédier des chansons
assez personnelle en première ligne
pendant cette crise sanitaire du colis
de 19
michael aknine et l'un d'entre eux
bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes le directeur de l'école
de musique guitare influences qui est
situé à versailles est aussi à viroflay
vous aussi vous avez poussé la
chansonnette pour le monde médical on
écoute tout de suite un extrait dans une
main c'est certes ces cris neutre à
venir dans leurs mains un destin celui
de se courir
dans une main tout se tient l'objet
d'audits et dans leurs mains c'est
l'humain qui donne la force de tenir
cette chanson était l'actrice appelle
dans une main racontez-nous déjà son son
histoire pourquoi avoir fait ce titre
m'a tout d'abord l'inspiration de la
réalité et de ce qu'on vivait et quand
on est un artiste ou qu'on a un support
pour d'expression ben on l'utilisent
pour dire ce qu'on ressent profondément
et c'est vrai que dans une main pourquoi
une main parce que la main et c'est un
symbole c'est le symbole d'une de
l'action et de la bonne ou de la
mauvaise d'ailleurs c'est un petit peu
ce qu'on dit dans cette chanson est là
les mains étaient tellement art lente
quand on voyait tous ces soignants la
main c'était le le prolongement du coeur
en fête prolongement de finalement de
lui mettre de l'humain qui a donc
repoussé soignants qui ont été d'une
dévotion et d'une générosité d'une
disponibilité absolue et je crois qu'on
a tous été complètement à genoux devant
ça eh ben voilà donc à la musique du
couvent a fait sa suisse a sa logique
c'est à dire qu'il fallait faire un truc
donc on a fait une chanson dans un cadre
très confiné avec les moyens du bord
avec des images d'internet jeux libres
de droits
oui je vous vois dans ce clip on voit
aussi plusieurs images d'une banque
libres de droits c'est ça voilà alors
c'est des images qui sont soit libre de
droit soit des images qu'on peut acheter
soit des images qui étaient aussi issu
d'un court métrage qui avait été qui
avait été retourné par marjolaine de
l'éclusé et puis dans lequel on retrouve
bruno solo et qui est un petit court
métrage qui qui se joue à huis clos dans
un hôpital
donc c'était vraiment le lien est
évident et on voit deux animateurs de
l'hôpital venir les conforter donner un
petit peu d'un mot aux enfants malades
et c'était en lien effectivement avec
l'actualité aussi donc on l'avait cru
dans le type et puis voilà et c'est vrai
que c'est un clip voilà de l'émotion et
de et d'admiration fait pour le corps
médical
ils peuvent 100% confiné on a compris
les paroles à la mélodie
elles vous sont venus pendant ce
confinement vous les avez écrit pensé
pendant pendant ce confinement
ouais en partie notamment le refrain
surtout le couple et je l'avais un petit
peu en tête
on a toujours des coupes de petite
musique comme ça qui se baladent et puis
à un moment donné on trouve le terrain
de là pour leur donner vie et c'est vrai
que que c'était une ambiance jazz un peu
jazz swing jazz manouche
comme pour nous prenait beaucoup à
l'école et qu'on aime aussi transmettre
et enseigner c'est un jazz très vivant
très très touchant et avec beaucoup
d'impact mélodique et c'est vrai que je
restais un petit peu dans cette ambiance
là et ça colle bien je crois
effectivement au message
avec ce rapport aux mains vous l'avez
dit prolongement du coeur de ces
soignants et ça permet aussi de
d'évoquer les autres professions parce
que à travers cet hommage au personnel
soignant vous souhaitez aussi rendre
hommage aux personnes qui sont en 2e 3e
4e ligne de cette crise sanitaire
en fait je crois dont le mot main on
peut un peu tout inclus c'est à dire
qu'à travers la main on peut rendre
hommage à effectivement à l'action en
règle générale quelle qu'elle soit et on
l'a vu à travers cette crise que
effectivement vous avez raison de le
souligner il n'y a pas que les soignants
il ya énormément de gens qui étaient
sans qui on aurait pu
pouvoir se se nourrir s'approvisionner
en différentes choses donc effectivement
c'est un hommage à tous ces gens là qui
ont été suis vraiment sur le front qui
ont été présents à qui on rend hommage
mais évidemment au premier lieu aux
soignants qui vraiment jouer leur vie
quoi
entre moi qui donnait des cours par
skype à mes élèves et un soignant qui
est le matin avec des gants en train de
soigner ce qu'on n'est pas sur la même
sur la même jauge quoi donc
effectivement oui c'est un hommage à
l'humain stade d'abord et cette crise
révèle aussi beaucoup de choses sur
l'humain mais pas qu'eux aussi sur un
système sûr après qui peut déboucher sur
d'autres thématiques mais je crois que
mal à la main c'est ça cette solide de
la main c'est de dire qu'on peut
construire comme détruire avec cette
main et que là on a une déclaration
d'amour
enfin ces soignants un dernier mot pour
vous demander quelle est la suite pour
vous on imagine que l'école votre école
de musique et est fermé en ce moment
même si vous le dites vous continuer les
cours à distance vous espérer reprendre
les courants en physique dans les
prochains mois les prochaines semaines
en présentiel à présentiel j'ai
découvert seulement le komo présent
sièges
mais ces présidentielles mais même
présence y est c'est vrai que c'est un
mot qui redevient très court en ce
moment donc effectivement on espère
réouvrir au 1er juin en présentiel donc
avec avec nos élèves dans la mesure où
ça se passe bien au niveau du
déconfinement mesure où les choses se
passent de façon sereine et que des gens
ont bien compris toute l'histoire des
gestes barrières qu'il faut adopter et
c'est donc si tout ce que tout ça se
passe bien on devrait réouvrir au 1er
juin
voilà merci excellent aknine je rappelle
directeur de cette école de musique
guitare influencé et auteur de ce titre
dans une main que vous pouvez écouter en
intégralité via le lien qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran merci d'avoir été avec no
mercy surtout à vous merci à vous deux
en formation avant de vous laisser
d'abord du sport depuis azir vous pouvez
vous adonner de nouveau au cyclisme en
extérieur dans le respect d'un plafond
de 10 personnes et d'un espace de 10 mai
entre chaque personne pour les
professionnels de la piste en intérieur
l'entraînement pourra reprendre
seulement dans quelques semaines le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
elle rouvrira a partiellement que
courant juin et uniquement pour les
athlètes professionnels annonce de la
fédération française de cyclisme
hier le vélodrome lieu d'entraînement
bien sûr des coureurs de l'équipe de
france qui est située à montigny le
bretonneux
enfin cette bonne nouvelle pour ce haut
lieu du patrimoine yvelinois le château
de breteuil pourra rouvrir dès vendredi
prochain l'édifice de choisel bénéficie
d'une autorisation du préfet des
yvelines étant considéré comme un petit
musée le parc sera accessible dès 10
heures les visites du château possible
de 14h à 17h30 avec des horaires
supplémentaires le week end les gestes
barrière devront être respectées
technique autorisé dans le domaine mais
les terrains de jeux ainsi que la scène
du petit poucet resteront fermés le
château de breteuil qui offrira une
entrée gratuite au personnel soignant
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale merci de votre fidélité très
belle soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]